from jellied eels to poisonous plants
these culinary oddities put even the
most adventurous eaters
to the test feed your curiosity with
four of the strangest delicacies
from all over the world
[Music]
in a remote part of japan lives a highly
toxic plant called the cycad
and believe it or not people consume it
regularly
beloved and cherished by the native
people of amami oshima
eating the plant in its raw form could
kill you
amami oshima is home to hundreds of
types of toxic plants
the cycad has been a staple crop on the
island for generations
because it is so poisonous locals take
the necessary steps to make the plants
safe for human consumption
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
through the process of fermentation and
drying the poison is extracted from the
plant
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so these are jellied eels eels in jelly
jelly eels and these are eels with no
jelly like loads of eels drawers of eels
hold on to your seats this might get a
bit weird
[Music]
so we got this giant jiggly bowl of
jelly deals from this guy my name is
john chilvers i work for mix hill supply
in billings gate fish market we supply
live eels to the catering trade
public i've been selling eels for 33
years since i left school
well we've got some lovely eels here
these are all farmed
in holland but they're like the rolls
royce of the dilla dills
they're very very slippery like some of
their customers
back in the 18th century london's river
thames was crawling with these eels
nowadays john is one of the last few ill
suppliers in london
so john why were they so popular yeah
you need to speak to one of the older
fishmongers for that
uh okay then i'm 72 years old and i eat
it
every day perfect so frank of bradley's
fish supply
what made them so popular back then so
those days it was it was no brainer
everybody at jelly deals
it was an easy source to get um very
simple you put a
hook out and they catch themselves eels
are really edible and they were full of
goodness
the people didn't realize it then but
they were they were eating a real good
product
and we didn't have indian chinese
takeaway kebabs everything else
so it was a it was a source of food so
how do you make them
quite easy to prepare you to head off
guts out chop them in pieces
then we cook them the process of cooking
is more of an art
you need them to be very soft but if you
go past being soft all you've got is
mesh
thanks frank so pie shop owner kane
what do they go well with jelly deals
and stew dills
are very traditional with pine russian
liquor in the east end of london so
you know it's not for everybody the
world's changing a little bit
you do either like them or hate them
probably in the old days we would go
through
uh maybe 50 or 60 bowls of hills a week
probably now we might do 10 or 12. so if
you think about
food around the world you think about
paris and their baguettes
new york you think about the pizzas the
new york cheesecakes that's what
they're synonymous for london the
traditional food in london is pine
nationals
that is a staple diet and the taste
it's like eating basically a chunky
white fish
it must
[Music]
[Music]
my
meet the husband and wife team selling a
delectable treat on the streets of
bangkok
the couple met six years ago when batuy
was frequenting lex stall
they eventually were married and she
joined his business
today they sell a variety of deep fried
insects near khao san road
a popular tourist area while their menu
may vary
their process is the same so let's start
at the beginning
which is actually the end of the day
foreign
and if you think that all bugs taste the
same think again
[Music]
eating bugs used to be associated with
poverty in thailand but that's not the
case anymore
and it's not just tourists who enjoy
this novel treatment
is the support they provide for each
other each and every day
foreign
[Music]
what if i told you you can literally
eat fire yes literally
in india pan is a huge culinary darling
that's been around for centuries
it's a snack usually eaten after a meal
to help with digestion
it consists of a better leaf that's
wrapped around all kinds of different
fillings
like nuts fennel cardamom fruits
chocolate or even meat you can find it
anywhere but a small street food shack
in new delhi
[Music]
all right then but back to the
revolution he's sparking
recently he had an idea that would
reignite
the classic indian snack his shack was
famous
[Music]
for
you're really bringing on the heat okay
that was a slow burner i was just
warming up
okay okay
so there you have it india's hottest
[Music]
trend
you